[Music]
this week we've got old baby fern fight
and pimple toy it's the weekend scramble
[ __ ] do it again I did the beginning
the last take was way better okay okay
okay yes the first story there's this
baby that has been born from an embryo
that was frozen nearly 25 years ago whoa
yeah and it's so crazy because the mom
is 26 so the baby's like one year
younger than her basically the embryo
was like yeah how did that happen
so this is a donated embryo so the the
embryo was conceived back in 1992 I
believe and the mom was born in 91 yeah
why whoa yeah so this baby I'm so lost
the mom is the carrier right okay but
she gets I mean the it was donated to
her or like the embryo was donated so
then this couple was able to just bring
somebody back in 92 or 91 and then let
the embryo happen no they didn't pop out
cuz the mom was born in 91 no but it was
a donated embryo because they had to do
that for the donated embryo right yeah
yeah oh extract the the sperm and egg
they'll create the embryo and then they
didn't come out oh so you by later you
guys about that
[Laughter]
turn on the Marvin get it dude what that
does that
that's like Austin Powers but in Rio do
that just pick up where they left off
they're like oh we're gonna make a baby
and then I get frozen and they're just
like oh we're gonna make a boat baby
yeah the power of freezers gets frozen
and then it falls out and then it goes
back to life or something bacteria that
flies can die like you can kill them and
then you can put salt on them and then
they yeah oh my dad used to do all the
time you catch a fly he would drown it
and then he would like but I was dead
and it would be dead for like a minute
and then he would take some salt and be
like and then the fly would be like and
it'd be like Pet Sematary fly and that
is some crazy [ __ ]
well there are animals that hibernate
during the winter they just freeze
themselves and fish like lung fish yeah
about that
but there's there's fish and then but
they get frozen that do that yeah I
think maybe mom or bees do bees do that
like the freeze them and then it like
nothing I know they yeah someone told me
that they freeze something and then they
put them wherever they need to go and
then they thaw him out and then they're
like it was like a specific frog then
inside their blood they have like a form
of like antifreeze so wherever the
environment that they're in
they'll freeze over during the coldest
times and during springtime they'll fall
out and that antifreeze will we'll just
have their heart beating just enough so
whether like or it wasn't that it's
frozen in a cup
I don't either way that blood is very
unique yeah buddy froze and Avatar The
Last Airbender is frozen
in effect the baby and is it just like
it's a rail or regular baby like there's
a baby person
yeah so here's the family whoa I don't
get is that even has come it's not they
don't those babies that
so this the same thing as adopting but
she just wanted to go through the pain
exactly why would you do such a thing
that is the most beautifully stupid
thing I've ever heard in my life she
wants to feel you baby goes out but it's
not even her DNA it's not her DNA it was
a test-tube baby yes oh I think all
these types of babies the babies that
have been like frozen for a long periods
of time they call them snow babies okay
so that's a test tube is the slur for
the snow babies can't call him that they
get offended yeah so it was funny
because the mom the one this mom the one
that gave birth she was saying like you
know it's crazy like if she was born
when she was conceived like we could
have been friends
that's right raise all the moments yeah
the membrillo like when she when the
embryo was created she was like a year
and a half old
that is crazy if you believe that souls
into the embryo then like what if that
baby is 25 inside and just like I've
started a baby but so for the first 25
years the Spirit was just frozen has
this ever happened before
yeah they've well this is the first time
that it's there's a embryo that has been
born after so much time like this amount
of time but there have been other babies
than before okay I'm sure like you know
that's five years ten years the baby's
gotta be cute if they're not cute people
be so mean to them I'll be like you
lucky you [ __ ] cute right now I'm
taking care of your ass cause you're
cute that's what saving them yep if they
weren't cute oh boy dogs - it was like
dogs will wreck your house but yeah
they're so cute you're like oh oh you
cute little [ __ ] okay same thing with
like girls too isn't it mm-hmm like hot
girls always get away with saying like
some of the stupidest [ __ ] I think
that's why biologically like cats dogs
girls we're all getting cuter yes for
survival the cuter the matter there was
I was out in Kate towns I took the the
trips employees out because three of
them had had birthdays Oh so freaking uh
freaking there's a reason why I
specifically stopped going out at late
at night it's because they're the most
obnoxious human beings at that hour like
you just wanna [ __ ] some young people
yes just like everyone just drunk people
just obnoxious as [ __ ] right yeah and so
like I specifically remember this was
like so either with the so there's Roger
he's outside
he's one of my business partners and
this girl comes up and their friends are
[ __ ] right and it feels so [ __ ]
obnoxious if you see this video
apparently she watches us you're [ __ ]
annoying she's probably drunk so she
doesn't remember yes you hot dog huh yes
this was a problem all right
I'm talking to Roger right she goes oh
you should come drink with those two I
was like that's 1 a.m. I got ahead bow
she was no no drink with us and I was
like I'm okay right she goes uh what was
that I was like you trying to make a
joke right now aren't you there she goes
I think I smell [ __ ] and I was like so
I looked up and I was like so what do
you do for a living right
and she was like she goes I'm a producer
I was like no you're not so what do you
do
I [ __ ] work I was like no you don't
so what do you do for a living she's a
pretty angrier and angrier right and so
this girl just said they're saying the
same [ __ ] joke
I think I smell [ __ ] [ __ ] and I just
kept on so I just sat there I just
looked at her and I was like all right
[ __ ]
this is getting [ __ ] annoying so I
walked away and then she came up she
goes you're not gonna come drink with us
I was like [ __ ] don't you [ __ ]
understand get the [ __ ] away from me but
here's the thing
in my mind I poetess had worse things
but she was so pretty cute [ __ ] cuz if
it was likely I mistreat you waitress
ugly [ __ ] don't get away with
anything
like oh that's your nice version yeah
that's my nice version the worst I just
would have went in on her but it's just
like if they're ugly you just can't wait
to talk some [ __ ] yeah but I don't know
man I don't like drinking anymore it's
not as fun as it used to be maybe it's
just because it has to be around like
the right amount of people yeah I think
I like drinking around people I like
like that I already know not randos at a
bar not like stupid strangers coming up
to you being like who do you like they
do [ __ ] [ __ ] that's what I do
so what I do I used I don't see if I
used to have this game where like I
would hated going out but my single
friends would always want to go out and
like when I was single I was like fine
I'll go out with you and they'll be like
flirting with guys and getting drinks
and I [ __ ] hate that and guys would
come up to me and they'd be like the
douchiest guys which is why I feel
justified in this and I would just be
like yeah little they'll be like what do
you do and be like I you know the
raccoon hats like I'm it I make those
I'm an engineer and I don't even have
that conversation cuz I'm like I'm
trying to that's why I have this face
yep geo it's so much fun because then
they try their asses off and it's so
funny and you'll just play dumb you're
just like oh that's cool and they're
like they're like can I get your number
like no and they're like oh like why not
cuz I don't like you know really I'm
like no I don't like you like you like
children hospitals they try to save kids
I try to shut those down that should be
your next [ __ ] those kids protest in
front of them they make the signs for
the process yeah so for our next story
there was this flight that had to make
an emergency landing and it all stemmed
from farting now that fart
what do anything do about that guys or
is it a guy I bet they're bragging about
it like I'm I fart had to land a plane
guy not brag about that kind of [ __ ] by
far was so stank the whole plane had to
shut down I'm not proud of my farts
though I'm embarrassed of them no you're
not so you're embarrassed person would
try to hold them in or run to the
bathroom and let them loose there well
I'm honest so I face them but I'm very
embarrassed
that's courageous that's a real man
right there Faro Mike I [ __ ] up all
right and it smells like [ __ ] but I'm
embarrassed about it yeah that's a real
man right there I've never seen the real
man embarrassed before I was tiny I'm so
[ __ ] bashful there was this flight
from Dubai to Amsterdam apparently that
was a sneaky fly right there it was this
man on the flight that just kept farting
and then the the men around him asked
him like hey can you stop fighting and
it escalated to the point where they
started fighting well it's cuz they're
serving hummus all did everyone's
farting in there I know the man refused
to stop farting I have the right to
thought this is a human right yeah and
then so they ended up kicking every one
outfit that was in that row even had a
fistfight over over 40 like a stray
rumble uh well they're saying that they
if they were started fighting Wow fight
I mean I don't know I agree of the fight
but yeah I understand it I think I will
start fighting someone if they smell bad
yeah especially cuz I'm pretty sensitive
to human smell so if they're if they
smell horrible to me that's like saying
[ __ ] you Joe you know what I wish I wish
is that some people would understand if
you know that you have like smelly
[ __ ] feet the moment you board the
paint plane and you sit down take your
shoes off Oh take your socks off where's
the first part before it's it's there
and it's souks because that's what
happens right so they'll sit there and
turn the [ __ ] air things on oh my god
dude the smelly feet is the worst cuz it
just lingers I don't know that they have
smelly feet like there's nobody that
doesn't know that they have smelly feet
oh for sure where does it come for is it
like bacteria eat your sweat you know
can't they just get like hand sanitizer
and squirt all over their toes I'm
trying to kill that [ __ ] I was having
stinky feet in France and you know what
I did I got my a order it and I rubbed
it all over the sole of my foot and
inside of my socks
did it work yep you just gotta be
creative so like when you're walking a
lot you know you're sweating and then
your sweat soaks onto the show and then
the sole of your shoe just traps all of
that bacteria
yeah it becomes like boxing gloves do
you ever watch the soles of your shoes I
started to now like I just stole the
soles and my shoes into the washer now
because I'm like I've been working out
too much now it's like boxing feet
that's why people use the gold bond
powdered [ __ ] I got antifungal spray and
I always use it in all my shoes smell
fresh yeah this that's a preventative
measure I don't even eat it but I just
like having fresh feet makes me feeling
you're still selling them into the
washer and dryer to be honest with you
like the really crappy shoes yeah I just
throw them in the washer and say [ __ ] it
take it out after yeah stinky feet is a
problem though it sucks for you all that
sweat more because like I don't really
sweat that much so I don't have that
problem but like people that sweat like
they can't help but they sweat more and
then like then it just sits like that's
where it comes from
you can't help it because if you know
you sweat like a [ __ ] in the
wear sandals like there's ways look like
Dino some dudes I go train at the gym
and they'll bring for t-shirts because
they know they just sweat like a
[ __ ] and they don't want to be
dragging their [ __ ] sweat shirt all
over the place so like after each
exercise they're just switching teachers
and that's pretty dope that they're
being courteous about that you know I
recently came across this product on
Amazon that cuz I get really sweaty feet
whenever I wear my boots because there's
like no ventilation everybody we've got
calls in them I got this like little
lotion thing that ends up like trapping
your sweat and antiperspirant
there's no smell or just just like no it
doesn't like it doesn't sweat at all
it's like this film over your rear skin
and then just like I want to try that
for like my forehead and it'll [ __ ]
jog like five miles and see if this is
sweat like if I do like a rectangle
filling up with [ __ ] sweat oh can you
use as a condom like and then this pro
today would you wanna put that on your
dick I can try I mean [ __ ] it peels off
inside oh that's nice
the girls supposed to pee after right
yeah that's two different [ __ ] holes
oh [ __ ]
turkey baster to get that [ __ ] out hope
for getting that just to it always looks
like one down there it's not good to
like you with five kids and that's how
you guys were all born
that's more like smash cut that I have
no idea how you were all right so for
our last story there's this really
disgusting toy that's really popular
right now for people like who yeah who's
not here that love to pop pimples
there's an actual toy fabulous costume
that gives you that feeling of popping
pimples
what the [ __ ] is it that like [ __ ]
pig and you squeeze and the Dookie comes
off you should put a trigger warning for
people with Miss Sophie Sophie Mia or
something hey there's people they like
David but those those dots are too far
apart they have to be clustered together
know what reminded me of you the other
day I was peeing into the toilet what
the [ __ ] you know David he gets that
creepy the heebie-jeebies from seeing
like little holes I get that a little
bit too like looking at the front of a
lotus plant
yeah a little bit a little bit but I
know at David's I'm like I can relate I
don't know I got that feeling a little
bit when I was peeing into the toilet
and you know how sometimes you want to
play like battleships or you just want
to pee as hard as you can see only
bubbles you can create so I create a
hell of bubbles and I saw all these
little holes other oh that's like a piss
beer float this cluster no no that's
good oh great it's weird because some
clusters affect you as some know some
stock images on black I look at it and
I'm like oh that's weird
like what about a honeycomb honeycomb no
but the lotus flower fuzzy
so it was the same thing though like my
favorite Vietnamese restaurant has just
lotus flower pictures everywhere so I'm
just like
it's so good here's a clip of people or
this person playing with it come on come
on
my blackheads Julia needs that for sure
so gross
what did they fill it up with Vaseline
good oh it feels weird watching it this
is like it's like weird and relaxing at
the same time relaxing oh because you're
expelling it like you get after like
it's weird while it's coming out like
for me like I like watching the real
videos like were they yeah dude there's
these videos worth like they take these
tiny tweezers and they pull out like
they do close-ups on like your pores and
they pull out these blackheads and it's
so satisfiying it just like it was
between the guy that when they [ __ ]
turn like like ice cream or taffy or
like they're making paint like that's
[ __ ] satisfying you are a [ __ ] no
weirdo did you hear it I'm a weirdo but
she likes watching people's get piles
but I actually like her so that's a
different story
[Laughter]
so you can buy this kit here for 20
bucks I gotta get that for Julia they
give you like a little bottle to refill
like junk and then you can also buy that
and then there's also a brown version oh
thank you for being in looks like that's
like a stress ball for people who like
this stuff unless it's [ __ ]
disgusting
I don't like liquidy ones I like the
hard ones like the blackheads that come
out you know those videos like I feel
really bad for the people their skin is
really really bad yeah have you seen the
ones in like China or India or whatever
in it like that blackheads I don't like
the size of like almost a diver's it's
like a worm comes it's ridiculous
because I'm like I've never seen black
is word you could actually get a tweezer
and pull it out you don't I mean so
there you have you guys ever gotten one
of those big nose pimples oh you know in
the heart yeah it's like a pitcher's
mound yeah and you can't really tell
where the hole is so what you do is you
get a needle and you just shank it like
ten times and then you squeeze and it
comes out all ten holes that is
you're supposed to do I just wait to
walk are you doing yeah you just wait
until it ghost moves to the top and a
white hat bet it's the craziest thing
I've ever heard nobody is going to
relate to that at all because sometimes
you just want to get it out so this is a
pitcher's mound
I just shanked that [ __ ] from
ten sides and I squeeze it you're pretty
he's prison about his whole life that's
great and you're not even in prison
that's the thing didn't even ask to piss
like he's in prison like [ __ ] make
all these bubbles make it really fast
and violent have you seen this philetus
take two he shakes that [ __ ] like this
he doesn't the nitrate like you'll make
you up like when you're not looking yeah
like it's always a surprise their sex is
crazy always tell her to drop it so
trumpet [ __ ] so right now
[Music]